Ja.
Mit T-Shirt.
Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Gürbus. Ich bin als Sistemaar Synthetik Indar.
Ich habe eine neue Art von der Üblichen Art.
Ja, ja natürlich. Klar.
Okay, kurzum auflaufen.
Ich habe eine neue Art von der Üblichen Art.
Okay.
Ja, okay.
Wie heißt es?
Ich heiße Klaus Fischer.
Klaus Mikka Oda.
Genau.
Fischer.
Ja.
Frau Fischer.
Ja, ich bin ein Mann. Klaus ist ein Mann.
Okay.
Herr Fischer, wie alt sind Sie?
Ja, ich bin noch 67.
Man sind sie genau wie vorhin?
Am 18.15.54.
Am 18.54.
Okay.
Nein, nicht 74.
Am 18.11.54.
Ah, 50, ja stimmt.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt auch 67 Jahre alt.
Ja, wie schwer sind Sie?
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ja, ich bin so 18.70.
Und wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 18.70.
Ja, ich bin 18.70.
Ja, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 86 kg.
Und was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Wie kann ich Ihnen heißen?
Ja, also ich habe, ich habe seit einigen Tagen schon wirklich
heftige Schmerzen so im Lacken.
Und jetzt ist es so schlimm geworden,
dass ich mich überhaupt nicht mehr bewegen kann.
Und das strahlt also in die Schultern rein,
in den Arm rein.
Und ich habe so das Gefühl, ich kann das nicht mehr aushalten.
Ich dachte, das wird von alleine besser.
Ich habe auch mal versucht mit der Wärmflasche.
Aber jetzt ist es so unangenehm.
Ich kann mich kaum noch so rühren.
Okay, seit einigen Tagen.
Okay?
Ja, seit einigen Tagen ist das so schlimm.
Ein bisschen Rückenbeschwerden oder so Nackenbeschwerden.
Das habe ich schon längere Zeit.
Aber das ist jetzt immer schlimmer geworden.
Angefangen hat das, da habe ich eine schwere Komode
an die Seite geschoben.
Und dann habe ich gedacht, es geht wieder weg.
Aber nein, es ist wie gesagt immer schlimmer geworden.
Ich verstehe.
Und rechte ist leite, stimmt oder nicht?
Ja, genau.
Ich habe mich bereit in den rechten Arm
und in die rechte Schulter rein.
Okay, können Sie Ihren Arm und Ihre Finger bewegen?
Ja, bewegen kann ich die Schultern.
Aber hin und wieder habe ich das so,
dass die Finger ein bisschen kribbeln.
Okay.
Ich verstehe.
Und wie ist das mit der Schmerz?
Auf einer Schmerz-Kalabra, wobei einsteller
leichter sind, als der Schmerz.
Ach, also das sind schon wirklich,
die schränken mich schon richtig ein,
dass ich würde sagen, ja, bei sieben sind sie bestimmt.
Können Sie bis Ende zum Geschiff heran,
also nach der Schmerz-Kalabra.
Nein, ich halte das ja jetzt schon ein paar Tage aus
und habe nicht jetzt noch ein paar Minuten mit Ihnen gesprochen.
Okay, ganz gut.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben Warfgelische angewendet.
Das habe ich versucht, ja.
Ein klein bisschen besser ist es dann geworden.
Aber wissen Sie, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich mich ins Bett legen soll.
Und wenn man dann versucht aufzustehen,
nur, dass ich umdrehe,
dann weiß man gar nicht, wie man es anfangen soll.
Am liebsten hätte ich jemanden, der mich hochhebt
oder wo ich mich hochziehen kann.
Können Sie etwas mit dem Finger händen greifen?
Doch, das ist nur so, dass die Finger so ein bisschen kribbeln.
Okay, nur kribbeln.
Und haben Sie Taubheit geführt in Armen oder in Finger?
Taubheitsgefühl, ja,
dieses Kribbeln würde ich vielleicht als Taubheitsgefühl bezeichnen.
Aber sonst im Arm eigentlich nicht, nur in den Fingerspitzen.
Okay, verstehe.
Und haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihr Arm und Ihre Finger kalt sind
oder überwärmt sind?
Nee, Temperatur und Unterschied habe ich nicht gemerkt, nein.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen Schwellung ausgefallen?
Nein, geschwollt ist es nicht, nein, nein, nein.
Okay.
Könnten Sie bitte genau beschreiben,
ob Sie sich bezeichnen?
Ich würde Sie als Brennendechen bezeichnen.
Haben Sie auch Kopfschmerzen?
Hin und wieder so ein bisschen,
weil ich den Kopf irgendwie ja gar nicht bewegen kann,
habe ich das Gefühl, das strahlt auch so ein bisschen hier hoch, ja.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen Schwindelig ausgefallen?
Nee, gucken und hören kann ich noch.
Ist Ihnen Schwindelig?
Nein, nicht wirklich, Schwindelig ist mir nicht.
Okay, Herr Fischer.
Ich habe einige Fragen zu Ihren Eilgemeinsbüchtern.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Wasserlassen und Stuhlgang?
Ja, also ich habe ein bisschen eine Prostata-Vergröserung.
Da muss ich schon mal mit dem Wasser lassen,
habe ich manchmal ein bisschen Probleme.
Und ich nehme da aber auch einen Tropfen da.
Okay.
Und beim Schuhlgang haben Sie Probleme?
Manchmal habe ich ein bisschen Verstopfung,
aber nicht so, dass ich da Medikamente nehmen muss.
Okay. Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, zurzeit kann ich tatsächlich nicht gut schlafen,
wegen der Schmerz nicht, weil es nicht wie ich mich hinlegen soll.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Deswegen schlafe ich wirklich schlecht, ja.
Okay. Haben Sie viel bei Schuhlfrosse oder Nationalschweife?
Nee, das zum Glück nicht.
Okay, Herr Fischer.
Haben Sie schon gesagt, Prostata-Vergröserung ist ein bisschen unheimlich?
Ja, genau, das habe ich.
Haben Sie andere Krone, die Sie erkrankt haben?
Na ja, was man so in dem Alter halt hat, was alle haben,
ich habe ein bisschen Bluthochdruck.
Und dann sind die Fettwerte im Blut ein bisschen erhöht.
Ja, und ja, was ich da sehrlich auch habe,
und das fällt mir jetzt um die Augen,
gerade ich kann gar nicht gut husten,
weil der Nacken so weh tut.
Aber ich habe so eine chronische Bronchitis,
und dann nehme ich schon so ein inhalierspray dagegen.
Okay.
Und seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck
und erhöfte Blutfettwerte oder chronische Bronchitis?
Die chronische Bronchitis, das habe ich schon ewig,
das habe ich schon 15 Jahre oder sowas,
und mit dem Hochdruck und mit dem Blutfett werden,
das hat man so vor 10 Jahren ungefähr festgestellt.
Okay.
Was ist das für Sie dagegen ein, gegen Bluthochdruck
und erhöhte Blutfettwerte?
Ich nehme Sortis ein, wogegen mag das sein,
das weiß ich gar nicht.
Sortis 20.
Einmal täglich.
Morgens oder abends.
Das nehme ich morgens ein.
Ansonsten nehmen Sie andere Medikamente ein.
Ja, dann nehme ich noch Prostakurtropfen.
Prostak.
Prostakur heißen die.
Dann nehme ich morgen 15 Tropfen.
Und dann nehme ich noch einmal am Tag
ebenso ein Spray, Huck, Spiriva Spray.
Einmal täglich, morgens.
Genau.
Okay.
Wurde Sie schon mal operiert, Parfischer?
Ja, was man so hat.
Also als Kind hatte ich eine Mandeloperation,
da war ich 15 oder so.
Und dann ist somit, da war ich fast 40,
also schon ungefähr 30 Jahre her,
da ist der Blinder entfernt worden.
Okay.
Ja, sind beide Operationen,
Kopifikationslosung gelassen?
Ja, ja, da gab es keine Besonderheiten.
Okay, sehr gut.
Parfischer, sind Sie vorstandig geinst?
Ja, ja, ja, ja, vor allem gegen Corona bin ich geinst.
Ja, ja, sehr gut.
Okay, haben Sie, Irgin Felche,
haben Sie allergiengigenetwatt?
Ja, jetzt der Frühling, der macht mir das zu schaffen, ja.
Ich habe so eine, so eine Polenallergie
und man sagt ja auch Häuschnupfen, ja.
Und jetzt, wenn alles blüht und die vielen Polen fliegen,
dann wird das unangenehm manchmal.
Dann läuft die Nase halt und die Augen werden rot.
Aber ja, das geht ja auch wieder vorbei.
Okay, ansonsten haben Sie Irgin Felche,
allergie oder untertere Kompagnen?
Nein, nicht das ich wüsste,
sonst kann ich wohl alles vertragen.
Ja, sehr gut.
Parfischer, haben Sie?
Ja, ich rauch schon seit 30 Jahren,
rauch ich schon und dann fast ein Päckchen am Tag.
Ach so, okay.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, eigentlich so gut wie nicht.
Okay, gar nicht.
Ja, also wenn ich einmal im Jahr irgendwo ein Glas Sekt mit trinke,
aber eigentlich trinke ich kein Alkohol.
Ja, sehr gut.
Parfischer, bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht für mich,
das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Erfahrungen mit Drogen?
Ich mit Drogen? Nein, also da habe ich gar keine mitaus.
Das ist nur eine Routinefrage.
Okay, Parfischer, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, die sind natürlich jetzt schon groß,
die sind ja schon erwachsen.
Ja, wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Zwei.
Die sind gesund.
Ja, sehr gut.
Haben Sie, ich bin in Rente, ja.
Was haben Sie gemacht?
Ich war Versicherungskaufmann.
Okay.
Leben ist alter noch?
Nein, gucken Sie mal wie alt ich bin.
Nein, die sind beide verstorben.
Woran sind Sie verstorben, wissen Sie?
Auch meine Mutter, einfach ein Alterssweche,
die war dann hochgetagt, die war 86, 87.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob sie irgendwie eine schwere Krankheit hatte.
Und mein Vater hatte tatsächlich einen Herzinfarkt.
Okay, okay, Parfischer, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestartet.
Haben Sie etwas hinzuschieben?
Nein, Sie haben so viel gefragt,
dass ich gar nicht mehr weiß,
ob ich Ihnen noch erzählen könnte.
Ich glaube, ich habe Ihnen alles beschrieben,
was ich weiß, ja.
Okay, Parfischer, erst mal,
wenn Sie uns körperische Unterzüge
dann auch Röntgenaufnahme veranlasst.
Was wollen Sie denn röntgen?
Röntgen von Schutza und Haiz-Röntgen
für Diagnosezustellen.
Und natürlich werde ich auch buddhaf nehmen.
Je nach Befund werde ich mit Ihnen wieder gesprungen.
Ja, dann ist gut.
Dann warte ich darauf, dass Sie mich untersuchen.
Ja, okay.
Ja, das ging ja wie geschnitten Brot.
Meine Güte, super, ja.
Hat jemand noch Fragen dazu?
Vielleicht hat er einen Umfalt.
Ah, das ist auch ein Interesse.
Den Unfall hatte ich der ja nicht.
Er hat nur geschildert, er hat etwas Schweres gehoben.
Aber ein Unfall war nicht.
Eine Frage habe ich vermisst
und von alleine habe ich das einfach nicht gesagt.
Sie haben nicht gefragt, ob es irgendwas gibt,
das die Schmerzen verbessert.
Ja, genau.
Ein Hinweis habe ich, ich habe gesagt,
bei Wärme wurde es ein bisschen besser.
Aber Sie haben nicht gefragt,
wird es irgendwann schlechter oder besser?
Ja, genau.
Ich habe es schon gesagt,
das ist Atemerkennig ist.
Das tut beim Einatmen im Weh.
Sie haben nur bei Wutzen verschlechtert.
Ja, genau.
Klar, wenn man sich das vorstellt,
wenn man hat diese Wahnsinn,
man muss mit Druck pusten,
das tut beim Drandenken weh.
Aber Wärme hat geholfen,
da war die Frage gerade noch.
Ein bisschen, aber hat es nicht endgültig besser gemacht.
Aber Sie haben wirklich sehr gut gefragt.
Sie haben auch sehr schön immer den Namen genannt.
Sie sind auch sehr zügig und straight da durchgegangen.
Das ging wirklich sehr fix ab.
Danke.
Sind Sie schon bereit,
dass wir das nächste Gespräch führen können?
Oder brauchen Sie noch eine Sekunde?
Nein, ich kann so fort vorstellen.
Dann bin ich mal gespannt.
Hallo Obererstin, Frau Obererstin.
Ich bin als Sitzternerstin in der Notaufnahme.
Ich würde gerne einen neuen Patrianten
vorstellen, wenn Sie das erhältst.
Ich will mal sagen, dass Sie das erhältst.
Ja, das ist ein viel образter Gedanke.
Auf einmal haben viele diese
Die Schmerzen sind in der rechten Schulter und in der rechten Arm und in die Finger auf.
Und die Naht der Patienten, die einige Schwerer kommen, die in die Schmerzen aufgetreten.
Ah, okay, ja.
Und,
bei Wermen
per Besatz, per Besatz,
ich bin ein bisschen,
bei Wussten, per Schlimat, ich bin ein bisschen,
und der Partien,
ich bin ein bisschen,
bei Wermen und Schlimat,
bei Wussten, auf einer Schlimatkala,
und die Ausreder
leidet der Partien unter
Paris-Sedis in Finger,
und...
Beide Seiten oder eine Seite nur?
Inderechten Finger.
Die Finger in der rechten Hand, ja?
Ja, und
der Patient hat keine Kraftminderung,
ödeme
in rechten Seite,
und ja,
Fragen nach Trauma,
Rehstörungen, Verstörungen, Vertigo,
wurden verneint,
und die Verstörungen
sind in der Hand.
Und die Verstörungen
sind in der Hand,
in der Hand,
und die Verstörungen
sind in der Hand.
Und das war
ein bisschen,
mit der Patientin
gerade
in der Hand und
in der Hand.
Und das war
ein bisschen,
weil es
die Verstörungen
in der Hand
Als Kind wurde er tonsillektomiert und mit 40 Jahren wurde er appendektomiert.
Er ist vorstellenlich geimpft.
Er hat alleergiegegen, er hat alleergiegegen,
er hat sich binore und augenrötung äußert.
Er ist seit 30 Jahren, er raus, seit 30 Jahren ein Paketigarate,
das entschüpft 15 Paket.
Er ist in der letzten Zeit ein Alkohol, ein mein Projag.
Er ist verheiratet und hat es gesundet.
Er ist rettend und vorher hat er als Versicherung kaufmann gearbeitet.
Im Darfamilien Annamnese, Ergazdich, Dimuta, D'Arfata, ist am Yokar Infar Fershtorben.
Und D'imuta ist auf natürlichen Gründen Fershtorben.
Ja, auch so.
Muskel-Ris vielleicht.
Ja, nach der Kommode, ja.
Genau.
Im Betracht.
Um die Diagnose zu stellen,
werde ich den Patienten natürlich erst mal 12 Jahre unterzuholen.
Worauf achten Sie da besonders bei der zöberlichen Untersuchung?
Bei der Perpation werde ich die Nackenbereiche und die Schurte und die Arme abtasten.
Ja, und worauf achten Sie da?
Ja, sehr gut.
Und auch in Verhärtung, ne? Verhärtung ist besonders, ne?
Ja, und worauf gucken Sie?
Neurologische Untersuchungen.
Ja, genau.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Gut.
Und was würden Sie sonst noch machen?
Röntgenaufnahme der Nackenregion in Zwei-Ebenen-Ferrandesung.
Genau.
Und die Gebenesfalls kann man auch MRT-Ferrandesung.
Ja.
Und was würden Sie der guten Ordnung halber labortechnisch untersuchen?
Ja, der Patient leidet an die Artillerie und die Hyperlopidemie.
Und deswegen werde ich diese Werte wieder überprüfen.
Ansonsten werde ich die Entsunungsparameter beurteilen.
Und noch etwas, ja, Blutbild natürlich.
Ja, klar.
Okay, ja, jetzt, wenn sich herausstellt, dass der Patient tatsächlich einen servikalen Bandschreibenvorfall hat.
Ach so.
Was wäre dann die Therapieoption?
Als Erstebastnahme kann man konservative Therapie einneiden.
Die sieht wie aus?
Bewegung und Kraft der Muskulität ist wichtig.
Ja.
Also, was kriegt der verordnet?
Physiotherapie.
Ganz genau.
Aber was kriegt der denn als allererstes?
Allererstes.
Haben Sie die schon angeboten?
Anagetika.
Ja, genau.
Und das ist mal etwas gegen seine Schmerzmittel.
Und die Relaktation auf Verordnen.
Ja, also, was würde man, man würde ein Schmerzmittel und würde auch wahrscheinlich ein krampflösendes Mittel so ein bisschen geben, ne?
Genau, natürlich.
Und wie kann man das in die Reaktion machen?
Und, was würde man vielleicht noch mechanisch technisch machen können?
Massage oder?
Ja, ich denke noch an etwas anderes.
Physikalische Therapie oder?
Also, ja.
Giftchen, nein.
Ja, also so eine Halskrawatte, ne?
Halskrawatte, okay.
Ja, um den Hals zu dazwischen.
Ja, da kommt es.
Genau.
Und wenn jetzt die ganze Konservativotherapie keine Linderung bringt, was haben wir dann für eine...
Wir wollten operative Therapie einleiten.
Genau.
Ja.
Gut.
Ja, dann bin ich sehr gespannt, dass bei Ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt. Halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden.
Ja.
Was aus Ihrem Patienten geworden ist.
Und dann hoffen wir mal, dass es Ihnen bald wieder besser gibt.
Ja, okay.
Danke schön.